[Applaudissements]
trop jeune trop sévère disette l'avons
vianney qui va acheter avec nous toutes
les missions l'est m'bia n'est rien et
tu restes avec moussu content waouh
j'aime bien tu peux me faire on a quoi
elle va mais elle est où
- ou alors les témoins de lotus art est
normal et moi je ferai la clé derrière
mais t'es où vas tu veux rester avec
nous tu veux aller
je suis bien je suis captivé robert
lamarre et romy ont battu le reste je
suis très bien à ma chère en tout cas
merci d'être là tu es ravissante mais
vraiment eu à tuer france et marié nom
final juste c'est à ton style de mec
vianney et bakou
[Applaudissements]
je suis une cruche
il veut clair ils étaient inquiets selon
tous les deux et un 10 lots alors allés
en piste aux musiques musiques
excusez moi ou vous avez des moufles
manier voulu merci alex clos au liban
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
super frémont partenaires c'est un très
bon partenaire et dieu sait que j'en ai
dénoncé des slows avec lui bb&t chaud on
peut faire un on peut jouer tous les
deux c'est reparti à 10 milliards ben
vas-y tu l'apprends malade tout ça tout
de suite
et tu fais ce que tu faisais là tous
d'accord allez vas-y tous les dîners
dans ma tête
images du long métrage
tu fais les mois la bête la belle n'est
jamais sage tu diras tu sais ma famille
je n'ai jamais se tenait
et
et au diable toi et tes apôtres
je m'en vais
là
qu'est ce que j'aime ce mec j'aurais
voulu être vianney c'est pour moi c'est
le top du top
le top qu'est ce qui se passe chez rim
unique donnera magadoux c'était séquence
gênant
m
viviane et je vous aime pas je suis fou
de via nice tu es quelqu'un
j'aurais voilà si j'étais un si j'étais
un garçon j'aurais voulu être bien né
c'est d'ailleurs chez un garçon si
j'étais un autre homme
j'aurais voulu être vianney non mais
franchement c'est un modèle pour moi
vraiment que je vous dis je vous adore
merci on essaie toujours de mercier au
monde dans ma nature connais pas trop
mais ça va pas tarder
mais
monstre hommes
débile dame attend ce défi pourtant
[Musique]
avant
décrire le jour
suivant me vouland de fils en vie le
vivons nous vraiment
mais relancée en ville vivons nous
vraiment
mais volant de deals en tirerons tous
three mois
mais volant de ville en ville vivons
nous oui moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]